when four students at the University of
Idaho were brutally murdered more than a
month ago in their rented Home Police
didn't have any suspects at first but
today police identified the killer as
Brian coburger he's a graduate student
in criminology at nearby Washington
State University now many people are
wondering how co-burger was able to
commit this horrible crime and then
evade capture for so long
now Rob McQueen used to live in that
very same rented home where these
murders occurred and he says that these
killings would have required a lot of
planning uh Rob thanks for making time
to join us here you bring a perspective
and I think uh no one else has shared
just yet how did you find out that this
occurred in the place that you lived
when you were going through college and
what ran through your mind
Hi Chelsea uh thanks for having me on uh
so I actually found out about this uh
through group chat with my former
roommates where we lived together uh
when I was actually working in Ukraine
so it was a very quick group chat and it
it was really a shock to kind of sit and
think you have that initial reaction
about I can't believe that I used to
live there and then you have the
reaction of I can't believe this
happened in my state and I think it's
important to look at this not just in
the details that we can get so lost in
in a crime that's so brutal and really
has created so much conspiracy theory
and and thoughts and and speculation but
really look at it in the impact of the
lives and the family of the family of
those four people that were slain the
impact of the University of Idaho and
the Moscow community and the impact in
Idaho as a whole like this is not
something that normally happens in this
state like this is going to leave an
impact for for a very long time
yeah so Rob I mean you served in the
United States Army for 15 years you're a
military veteran you've deployed a
number of times and you were doing
humanitarian work in Ukraine and you
found out about this as you think about
those Halls and those rooms that you
lived in uh tell us what had to go into
this murder being able to commit such a
heinous crime in that house
so when you look at the layout of the
house right it's basically an old build
with a newer build on top and it's built
into a hillside so if you address kind
of the first theories with the the
surviving roommates that were living on
the first floor uh that they would have
heard something that they that they were
there you had to have heard it you have
to understand that the structure of the
house those first two rooms are built
just underneath the living room and then
are also built into a hillside so then
when you move to the second floor of
this house you get to the main level
that enters two bedrooms one bedroom
directly across from the kitchen and
next to the stairs that goes up to the
third floor and then that kitchen enters
onto a back patio which is on that
Hillside so that second layer where the
kitchen is where that second bedroom is
and where the stairs that go up that
move to the third floor are that is not
above those other two bedrooms so it's
really important to understand that so
you're not going to hear a lot from that
basement level there and then once you
move from that sliding glass door you
run directly in into the entrance to a
bedroom and then to your right you have
to go up the stairs and when you think
about a third floor you have to think of
this in college housing right so when
you move up to that third floor it's a
narrow stairway it enters into a very
very small hallway and then the entrance
to two rooms the room that the murders
took place in and another room that was
unoccupied and that is a really just the
layout and the complexity of getting to
that part you could either be
completely
not worried about the impact of what
would happen to you should you be caught
or you had to diligently plan and
understand the layout of that house to
move in and actually leave that space
without like really causing alarm and
being caught
yeah rob it is chilling to think about
the footsteps that that killer took to
commit that crime I know that a lot more
details will will be coming out very
soon thanks for sharing your first hand
account of of what could have happened
that day in that house I appreciate it
and thank you for your service
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight